outre des murs blanchis à la chaux
nous sommes au bout du monde chez
françoise arnoul vous savez que vous
habitez en place par une ferme
nous sommes en vie monsieur le prince et
nous sommes dans un dernier étage la
ferme être le premier en fait c'est un
grenier
c'était des petites chambres et ses
petites chansons devenues tellement et
c'est un hôtel c'était des petites
chambres et voilà je suis arrivé un jour
j'ai regardé par la fenêtre j'ai aimé
les toits qu'il y avait dehors alors
vous avez gratter le mur mais j'ai
gratté j'ai cassé et voilà ça a donné ça
et maintenant c'est françoise au coin du
feu
je veux dire que je fais j'aime bien mon
petit coin j'avais un côté plus chaque
jamais avec 7,7 pile de coussins et et
vous savez vous si vous vous y êtes fait
une niche pour vous dans la cheminée et
quantité niche pour vos livres il ya des
trous partout dans les murs il ya des
trous partout mais j'avais beaucoup de
livres alors il fallait bien les mettre
quelque part j'ai trouvé mon port
d'attache vous êtes quelqu'un de très
organisé non dans votre vie pratique
non je suis je suis pas quelqu'un
d'organisé nantes je trouve que c'est un
mot affreux m'organiser alors on ne sait
jamais c'est terrible je suis quelqu'un
d'instinctif suis pas quelqu'un
d'organisé mais ce quelqu'un
d'instinctif elle même certaines ordre m
une certaine couleur ou choses auraient
elles un bien-être un confort et un
confort moral
vous venez de tourner un rôle qui vous
plaît bien et qu'ils changent de skate
ça s'appelle ça s'appelle le dimanche de
la vie est un merveilleux roman que peu
de gens connaissent d'ailleurs c'est un
roman assez anciens de raymond queneau
et je dois dire que le roman est très
très beau mais jean herment qui a fait
son premier film est complètement entré
dans le temps
monde vraiment que nous et a fait un
film merveilleux et ce film vous ouvre
justement vous en avez l'impression
toute une partie de votre carrière qui
vous manquait dans des rôles différents
et que vous avez attendu rationnement
est un passionnant en même temps oui
impatiemment parce que parce que
finalement quand on est acteur on a même
joué souhait de jouer la comédie et
qu'on est très malheureux quand on la
joue pas et que je dois dire avec
beaucoup de patience
j'ai refusé plein de choses parce que
parce que j'ai plus envie d'être enfermé
dans un seul personnage et que j'ai
envie parce que j'ai évolué parce que
j'ai changé parce que je me suis
transformé physiquement j'ai envie de
faire d'autres choses
en général les années apporte seulement
ou un peu désillusion ou un peu de
fatigue vous ça vous amuse à l'aise dans
votre frigo plein d'illusions et plein
d'entrain et plein d'enthousiasmé et je
crois que j'ai beaucoup de joie bien sûr
ils regardent des flammes dans sa
cheminée et là des livres dans les
niches est là une chambre de châtelaine
et les halles est heureuse de vivre du
bonheur à vivre
merci pour la leçon de vie d'enfant
c'est pas une raison
si savoir vite je me permettrai pas de
donner des leçons j'ai bien dans ma peau
c'est tout et puis j'ai envie de dire
[Musique]